I think the main reason. In retrospect
the main reason for leaving the city
and coming coming to nimbin
and balance in such places was was
really to live our own lives.
I think that's that's the
fundamental part of it
that the it became it was becoming
increasingly in strongly obvious living in the
city living the lives
that our parents generation set up which
included sending us trying to send us to
fight a war in vietnam that we
fundamentally didn't believe in and
and becoming more and more involved in a
society totally dependent on oil and.
Resources which couldn't be sustained
at the level that we were using them.
And while they were particular
things wrong with that
that way of living.
I think now that the
most important thing was
that we wanted to have a life of our
own and i i really strongly think
that every generation should do that.
So that when we came up here
and we tried new forms of
relationship a new forms of family
and new patterns of responsibility for
children in new ways of living community
and new forms of property ownership
community property ownership
and so on.
Some of those of just become part of the
mainstream some of them have been dropped
altogether.
Now many of us like to have private
property allow there are still some very
successful community properties
around and these are increasing.
But now they tend to be what are called
multiple occupancies where it's almost a
strata titled system where everyone has
their small block of land with their house
on it and this community ownership
of 100 acres or so. I've of forest.
In the middle. So it's a it's a
nice combination i think of both
and it's worthwhile to find out what are
the things which which people really need
how much private property. How much.
Exclusivity of relationships and
continuity relationships that people need.
I think
when we came from the city we we came out
of a system which was far too repressive
and as in all revolutionary movements
we went to the opposite extreme.
And now we're those of us in that
generation and probably coming back
and finding some some middle
ground which suits us.
Hopefully the next generation will
take off from our middle ground and
and find a ground that
suits them. So that.
The fact that now we don't all
live community and we don't all.
Continue to share each other's.
Partners and
that some of us there in monogamous
relationships i don't think is in any sense of
failure it was it was
worth while testing it
and changing it to whatever
extent we needed to
and finding out for ourselves
what what worked for us.
That's a good thing to find out.
That's a much better thing to find out
than to have simply passed on to you.
Fondest memories of him and would have to
be the healing festivals in the music.
Just the.
Probably my very fondest memory
is being shared poohed by three
or four people.
I massaged by six or
eight people all singing
and chanting delightfully no
no heavy single personal vibes
just just bodily being part of a group
of people in that way. The color.
The colour of people's dress
costume you might call that
and just a continual music that was
made by us and really the notion
that we were doing all this we were
having this marvelous magic creative
interesting energetic lifestyle and
it was only we who were doing it
and i think that's the real.
That really came from the concept
the original concept of aquarius
that graeme dance and
johnny allen set up is
that the festival was to be just to come
from the energy and what people did there.
It wasn't as festivals are now.
Or even woodstock was paid bands coming
from somewhere else to entertain a group of
consuming masses because that's the
lifestyle we want to leave in the city.
It's boring to be in the audience
and consumer all the time
and it's wonderful to to have adventures
and to do it yourself when you can.
I've seen. I've had probably
the best experiences
and had the best music in my life in.
And of course a good
circle gets going where
that sort of energy attracts
people who have studied many years
and have developed their real skills
in music and art and drama and so on.
And those people would. Would come
to an im and we would see also
that there is real value in in
really skilled musicians but
but there's also wonderful fun in.
You know homegrown musicians and eventually
the two the difference disappears.
The whole idea was to build a a
life style in a place where.
They are say the best people would
would want to come and live
and they did.
This. I think in the early
days of nimbin. It was.
You know to be a bit brave
and a bit self-sufficient
and have a bit of background
to leave. To leave the city.
There was nothing here. So it
wasn't easy. In any sense.
I imagine a few people came to
the aquarius festival and could.
Without doing anything themselves kind of.
You know the offtake from
take from the others
but actually moving up here there was
there was nothing we had to make our own
relationships our own fun our own
music and and that was great
but i think only people with a with a
certain energy and enthusiasm can do that.
I don't know about the
concept of madness at
that time i was very much part of the
anti-psychiatry movement taking my fourth
year honours psychology students to the.
The psych hospitals and showing how they
were diagnosed and brutalized and that
that how that wasn't necessary wasn't
as necessary as as what was happening.
And.
So i don't know whether we were mad i'm not
sure whether we were people who couldn't
cope in the city and came to a
place where we made a lifestyle
that we could cope with or whether
we were just creative and energetic
and wonderful and amazing. And the truth
is probably a bit of both as it is we.
I suppose we've migrants in any situation.
I guess migrants are the best in the worst
of of any country the most creative
but also the most dissatisfied the
strongest but also the least.
Well adjusted i don't know about all that.
To a certain extent i think that
that real difficulties including
possibly madness and so
and to some extent could be
could be coped with an absorbed
and used an integrated.
In the sort of life they were leading
because it was it was trial.
Well but it wasn't organized it was there
that you could your energy was welcome
but it wasn't on demand from
one to five and i think
that sort of continuity of of the
presence of other people without the
without. Divided demands
and structures and.
Regular demands of people.
Allows a lot more people to to adjust
and be energetic and give of their best
and then a very ordered.
Social system does.
I think too in those in those early days
we we were fascinated by the differences
between people between
us we all was very much.
The thought that we all
had something to offer.
And if it was really really weird
or far out that was a good thing.
Certainly wasn't threatening.
You know a real freak was someone who was
who was valued in an interesting rather
than someone who had problems always
diagnosable or who couldn't quite make it
or adjust or control
and skills.
And i remember sleeping one
night in a dome made of.
Probably mud bricks and concrete.
That was completely studded with
bottles of different colors so that
when you lay down on the ground.
You looked out along the length of
a bottle to the to the moonlight
and the whole thing was
with a multicolored.
Sort of psychedelic heaven
dome over the top of you.
And somebody lived in that i mean.
How could you judge a bit of.
How could you judge whether that
person was mad. I just amazing.
And i think there was a lot in the eastern
spiritual tradition which which had a
lot of trouble distinguishing
between madness and.
Spiritual.
And spiritual craziness.
And my friend harry freeman the psychiatrist
in our sesay has a lot of trouble to
sing sing to in a spiritual transformation
and an episode of madness in
and wouldn't be too keen
to tell which was which.
Harry gumboots valley an
amazing person in my memory.
Harry gumboot was out a tangible falls
where we all used to eat community in the
early days at the white house every month
or so the christians would come around
and feed us and play music and we'd chant
and sing their songs it was wonderful
but then we had to listen to their to their
10 minute speech about how the world
was created two hundred sixty seven
years ago and even we couldn't take
that sort of thing.
So the next time they came we made
up a song called harry gumboot.
And instead of harry rah
always saying harry gumboot.
And there was actually a person called
harry gumboot on top of at the time so it
was it was our way of the being spiritual
in joining with anything without being.
Without being silly about it. Losing
a sense of fun and perspective.
I mean even hippies can't believe
that they were was created two
hundred sixty seven years ago.
Once when i was living at explained farm.
A few of us had been to have been to
thailand to do meditation retreats and.
A couple of the people bought
a time monk back with them.
Very much an iteration of us setting
up our own lifestyle and communities
and so on and i guess instead of
building a church we bought a time monk
and build him a little dome up in the.
Up and one of the shelves of land
high above the the plan farm.
One of us at a time would be his his
keeper to look after him and every morning
and afternoon there would be a meditation
sitting around 10 a channel time monk.
So that that that's how
we provided for our.
That was our church i suppose
for our little community for.
For those few years that it
lasted and tonnage and went down.
After that to stay in what in sydney. At.
Once when i asked on a chain what the
secret of life was he said drink coffee
and sleep that is a secret of
life drink coffee and sleep.
So if you want to have your own resident
time monkey discover and get one.
You'll find someone who you always
find some part of the world
that will cooperate with any scheme
that's got enough imagination
and there's got good energy to it.
There were very few people in them and who
set themselves up as gurus. Although.
There are a couple of
exceptions to that statement.
The world is full of gurus and it was
wonderful to be able to to adopt gurus
or ideas from eastern religions and practices
and and build them into one's life
and then then bill.
No just like being able to read
the literature of the the world.
They're just ideas they're just.
Ways that some people have found to.
Broaden and deepen their spiritual and
magic aspects of their lives. I suppose.
We had a good. We always had a good
level of skepticism about things.
They hurry questions of fun
but they always thought i was as being
pretty strange really had been the world got
plenty of room for strange
people and the world
that we left in the city didn't have room
to strange people and it was its loss
that it didn't. It was in the
diagnosing and excluding and and.
One of the the original gurus i suppose
in the city was marshall mcluhan.
And then at a more intellectual level.
Herbert marcuse who wrote a book
called one dimensional man and
that was probably captured what we what we
didn't like about what life was like in
the city. It was one dimensional you
fitted in. A narrow you didn't have ideas.
We never talked about one
didn't talk about politics
or religion certainly didn't talk about
magical sexuality or drugs or fun
or adventure that was all what
they did in the 17th century
when there was a world to explore
and suddenly with the help of some
psychedelics we we found there was an inner
world to explore and it was
really nothing to stop us.
I suppose.
I think i think the presence of psychedelics
a bit of a list that was around and
and some of the good dope was i
think it was probably fundamental
and basic to two. To the
whole new age thing.
Really i think it probably
was. I think it just.
Let you see that there was another.
Whole dimension of possibilities
about human life.
And then of course you could
read eastern literature and.
And some of the some of the more
spiritual western literature and know
that people had lived the experience of
those dimensions of life in the past
and why weren't we doing it.
That's our birthright that's part of what
we're capable of as human beings and
and we wanted to be able to do it.
And it probably just looked a lot
easier to do it out in the countryside.
Amongst ourselves.
Consenting to do so rather than to have
to fight to do it in a city where it was
thought of with.
With this belief and fear
and so on.
You get very much a sense of place of nimbin
in virtually anyone who spent any time
here ends up coming back.
Whether to stay if they can or
whether they just keep coming back.
There's something very magic about the
fact that this is in the mountains.
There's a lot of days when it's misty
rainy quite quite hobbit like.
That was probably
and one of the one of the very important
bits of western literature that
that informed our whole way of life was
tolkien's books had to read talkings books
and then you'd be just about
prepared to leave the city in come
and live in in this lovely hobbit country
where of the misty mountains where you
can live around the mountain from somebody
else they only 10 minutes walk away
or five minutes walk away.
And yet hardly see them and to know
that there's a lot of really really magic
unexplored nature between you and them.
And it kind of all falls for
example a big commune here.
The whole place is joined by walking tracks
which go across numerous creeks and.
Walking barefoot around tracks in the
rainforest to see. Your neighbors.
In the misty days are in the evenings
with glow worms on the way and.
Animals in the trees it's just a life
it's so full and rich of nature and magic
and spirituality and.
That's very different from living
in a fibro house in bankstown.
And going to sydney university
too and. Something or other.
Or teaching it.
Ok.
To.
Pimp enough.
There.
I am in a. So.
My name's diana roberts currently an
alderman on little city council which i have
been for the last 15 months or so
and i'm a herbalist i own my own business
in limon which i share with a friend
and i've been practicing in
them and as a herbalist on
and off since i moved
here eight years ago.
I live on a community about 12
kilometres from limon with nine other
households.
We have 16 children 15 adults
so we're quite a big community
and i have a five year old daughter.
About 13 years ago when
i was living in sydney.
My partner and i decided that we would
really like to live to move to the bush.
We both came from a rural area and i use.
And we lived in sydney for 10 years
and didn't really want to be part of
that sort of environment anymore
not because we didn't like it
but because we wanted to change
and wanted something else
and we got together a group of
people there were six of us
and we spent about six months looking for
land in rural areas along the coast north
of sydney and the further we got from
sydney the cheaper the land became
and we eventually found this
piece of land near nim and
that was a piece of land
that we could afford and
that we were also able to develop
as a multiple occupancy so
that was just over 10 years ago
and here we are. Components.
It's a hundred acres that used to be
it probably once was dairying country
and then as the land became more
and more degraded it was basically disgracing
country but it was a very sort of.
Low grade. You know low
quality piece of land
when we moved here we've got eight
or nine families now living here
and we've all built our own houses are in
the process of building our own houses.
We are not a sort of a tight community
in that we don't sort of eat together
and spend a lot of our time together.
However we're a very sort of
closely knit community and
that we socialize together a lot. We
play volleyball together once a week.
It's a very supportive community
and we're all good friends i'd have to say
it's taken quite a long time to get to
that point we've seen people
who've come and gone.
Especially in the first five years
that sort of a real initiation time
for people who move on to multiple
occupancies in
that you know you have to learn to live
with a group of people you don't have
anything to live in. So you're
also building your houses.
It's a very stressful time generally for
relationships because you suddenly spent
spending a lot of time with your partner
which you might never have done before.
So it's almost like you getting to know
your partner you're getting to know your
family and you're getting to
know this group of people
that you've never met before
and you're living in you know pretty primitive
conditions in the early days i mean
i lived under just a piece of tin
about two meters by three meters.
I slept in a tent with go and
as and snakes and you name it.
Jumping ants and all sorts of
interesting little creatures.
I endured about six months
of almost continual rain
when i first moved here which was the
most frustrating experience for somebody
trying to build a house and get
a decent roof over our head
and i also found myself in a situation
of building my own house when.
Prior to moving here
and i reckon i could count on one hand the
number of times i've picked up a hammer
probably never used a drill in my life
and i've never ever seen
a four inch nail before
and i know all those things
intimately now and i truly have.
You know a house to live in
that a lot of which i've built
myself i'm quite proud of it.
I think for the people who've
lived here in that thousands
that have different ways
to build their houses
and we have some stone houses where we've
sort of quarried you know made small
quarries in some in some of our hills
but generally we're all pretty comfortable
and i think you know happy with the
lifestyle i mean it's it's a very sort of
pleasant.
Although very sort of challenging
in confronting way to live.
We had a lot of struggles
in the early days
when we came here we had struggles with
our neighbors who were very resistant to
the idea of having a multiple occupancy
next door and we went through.
Fairly unpleasant processes of taking
neighbors to court and till we realized
that really you know that sort of
the legal way wasn't the way to go
and it was you know much better to try
and negotiate solutions with neighbors
or really just to sort of let them be and
let time sort of heal those divisions.
We also had difficult times.
You know between ourselves
just learning to live together
and then we also had very difficult
times with council we put in a
development at vacation after we bought
the land which was fairly common practice
in those days
and still is you know to say in some ways
i mean you get a few developers who put
in the development up a case and
before they actually find the people
but for many people setting up a community
here they'll find the people find a
piece of land and then they put in the
development application to council
and in those days i think we would have put
ours in about eight years ago it was a
very unfriendly council and
unfriendly council staff
and we had an incredible struggle trying
to negotiate what we felt were reasonable
conditions under which our
development could be approved
and it took us quite a few years and
it cost us quite a lot of money
and once again you know the only options
to us in the end were to follow the legal
process and to take counsel to court
and we actually decided not to do
that ultimately because that you know
it becomes a very different scenario.
Once you're in court and the actual reality
gets lost in you know in the legal
or sort of jargon them practice.
No.
Here.
I think there's more councils a much more
friendly council now as far as multiple
occupancy goes although there's still a
lot of prejudice amongst some of the
or the man and staff
and i think actually a lot of ignorance
about multiple occupancy last style
and what it actually means is this vision
of a whole lot of hippies living in
substandard conditions in the hills.
Whereas in fact you know
it's not like that at all.
And i've often thought it would be really
valuable to take you know people on tours
of multiple occupancy so they can
actually see how people live.
You know what the values
are of those people.
I mean the values of those people are no
different to people in the wider community.
It's just there's this perception
that you know that we are different.
I think on other councils though perhaps
you know the situation isn't as friendly
towards multiple occupancies
or as easy i'm not saying it's friendly
in lismore council but it's easier
and we saw a situation in chi oval
council about three years ago where they
actually demolish somebodies house.
This was a bamboo house it
was a really beautiful house
that had been built by a
local bamboo house builder
and was owned by a woman who
had three young children
and i think the perception
on cuyahoga council was
that here we had a woman
living in an illegal house
that was meant to be a temporary dwelling.
But an illegal house in substandard sort
of third world conditions because she had
a rammed earth floor and she had a
pit toilet which many of us had and
that it was a bamboo how.
It's like you see in asia and that created
all sorts of sort of shock horror
and incredibly negative
ill informed comments.
I feel from people who you know
in a position to know better
and should be better informed
and in a very sort of heavy handed way
council came out and demolished the house.
Fortunately we don't see you
know that happening too often
that there was a situation in this more
and about 78 maybe a little bit earlier
where lismore council tried to demolish a
couple of houses and they
lost that battle in court
and i think they've really sort of laid
off since then because it costs a lot of
money. You know for councils
to go to court the way
that we see the sort of prejudice coming
through now is just in the the conditions
the dip laced on multiple occupancies
when they put in their development
application the standards
that council requires of them and i
think they're often unreasonable
and also there's not a recognition
that multiple occupancy was designed
really as a form of development
that would provide low cost
housing for low income people
and if you impose really harsh development
conditions onto those people then there
you know they're not able to
comply with them for a start.
So they end up living in a legal situation
and it would price multiple occupancy into
a much more sort of middle class market
so you disenfranchising low income people
and you know really the only opportunity
they have to own their own piece of land
and to build their own house to
give them some sort of security
that i believe everybody has a right
to sort of lost the train now.
Local politics. Do you want to
focus on them and politics. Yes.
Ok.
Politics in them and is
a very complex issue
and i must say in the 15 months
that i've been on council life found it
particularly difficult it times to come to
terms with you'll meet somebody for
instance in one so she'll situation
and they'll say one thing and
then you'll hear that in a.
You know another social situation with a
different group of people they've said
something quite different for me i think.
My observation in nimbin is
that the turning point in community
politics happened probably about two
and a half years ago when the
last federal election was held
and this seat which had been traditionally
a national party seat was lost by
the national party to the
labor party and i would say
that helen caldicott who was a long time.
Peace campaigner who
stood as an independent
and had a great deal of appeal to people
in this electorate was really the key
reason why that seat was won by labor
and lost by the national party
subsequently to that they were.
A resurgence of activity by the
national party within this whole area
and nim and wasn't sort of spared that act
that activity at the same time in
nimbin there were people developers who
moved into the area who bought up a lot
of the land surrounding the village
and who were very keen to
see nim and develop so
that was putting a lot of pressure
on their men and combined with
that there was their debate about whether
to put in a centralized series came into
the village that.